♪♪
-Hey, sorry if I seem off.
My mic was all [bleep] up.
It's gonna be a short one today.
We're only correcting
two episodes of the show.
We didn't do an episode
on Monday.
We were out in L.A.
for the Emmys,
and then on Tuesday
I stayed in L.A.
for an extra day
to demand a recount.
I regret it.
It was petty and small of me,
and then I think to punish me,
they did it right
in front of me,
like,
stacked up all the ballots,
so it was a real sort of
visual representation.
And then they said,
"Do you see how we got there?"
Um, oh, we --
I guess yesterday's
"Closer Look"
gave Trump a hard time
because he said he won Iowa
three times and he has not
won the Iowa caucus three times.
But some of you
pointed out he did
win the general election
in Iowa three times,
so that maybe
that was what he meant.
And, uh, I apologize.
You know, Mr. Trump,
I owe you one.
And much like
when you owe somebody,
I'm never going to repay you.
Had a joke about, uh,
they found some cocaine,
you know,
floating in the Caribbean.
And the punchline was, people
became suspicious that cocaine
was in the water when all
the fish were flying fish.
Uh, it did better.
But in my defense,
everyone here has seen it.
One of the fish in the photo
I was told was
a largemouth bass,
which is a freshwater fish that
would not be in the Caribbean.
But once fish hear
there's cocaine in the water,
they'll --
they'll make the trip.
Maybe not a largemouth bass,
but you know who loves cocaine?
Large-nostril bath.
Bass.
Good news is, I don't think
it would have played any better.
The interesting thing,
you can --
the way you can tell
a large-nostril bass
isn't from the large nostrils.
It has a really long pinky nail.
You know who else loves cocaine?
Blowfish.
Is that a...? I don't think
that's a dad joke.
You know why?
Because to tell your kids,
you'd have to explain cocaine.
Fish who like cocaine.
I'm going to stay on this.
I should bail, because I don't
feel like it's been as rich
an area as I thought.
Fish who like cocaine
are easy to catch,
because when they hear people
are doing lines,
they swim right over.
But they're --
they're fishing lines.
Hey, we showed what we called,
we described it
as a Japanese game show
where contestants get hit
in the testicles.
A bunch of you said
that's actually
a clip from
a comedy variety show.
Those were comedians,
not contestants.
You know, I did
a variety show for years,
and I can't think of
a single fellow cast member
who would agree to
get hit in the nuts.
Oh, Samberg.
A door did not blow
off the Alaska Airlines flight.
It was a door plug.
"Plug" isn't a good word
to invoke safety,
or to evoke safety,
if that's the right word,
you [bleep] monsters.
"Plug."
Imagine being on a cruise
and them telling you, "Good
news. Your room has a plug.
Try not to jostle it."
Speaking of, I said
Vivek Ramaswamy blows harder
than the open door
on Alaska Airlines.
Many pointed out
the physics of such.
It would not blow.
It would suck.
So apologies to Vivek Ramaswamy.
You suck harder than the open
door on Alaska Airlines.
I said the weather
in Iowa was below 30.
It was 30 below,
but also 30 below is below 30,
so you're embarrassing
yourselves.
Did a joke about
an Australian teen
whose mom found a snake
in his sock drawer.
The punchline was
the teen speaking,
and a lot of you asked,
"Why did you not use
an Australian accent?"
The short answer is you have all
given me a crisis of confidence
when it comes
to my Australian accent.
It was something
I felt good about,
I felt loose with,
I liked doing on air, but now...
it brings me no joy to do,
and that's on you guys.
And the fact that you did
that to me is not
[ Australian accent ] all right.
Hey, we --
last week in "Corrections,"
we showed a panda chasing
a peacock around,
"Benny Hill"-style.
We played a song,
and someone wrote,
"I can't believe you could
afford the musical rights
to 'Yakety Sax.'"
We fully can't.
That was 100% a sound-alike.
And you know how bad I feel
that Benny Hill could afford
that song and I can't?
The man was a letch.
I liked that show
because "Benny Hill,"
watching "Benny Hill" as a kid,
it was the first time I thought,
"The British
aren't better than us"
Oh, I mentioned --
[ Clears throat ]
No, I forgot it.
I mentioned
that Pure Balanced Keto
has been using images
of Kelly Clarkson and I
without our consent
online to sell their product.
Two things.
One, you should never use
someone's likeness
without their consent.
Two, I'm happy to announce
my new product, Keto Power Plus.
It's a very similar pill.
I know you've tried it, Kelly.
What do you think?
-I love it.
-That's great.
You can go now.
[ Laughter ]
So cool that she showed
up for that.
Last week,
showed my birthday present
from the camera crew.
Lynn Swann jersey,
meant a lot to me.
Um, he was wearing --
He wore number 88,
and then a bunch of you
were like,
"Hey, I wouldn't show that.
You know '88' is like,
a white supremacist symbol."
Hey, white supremacists, enough.
Enough. The white supremacy,
bad enough.
Stop taking other [bleep]
and making it yours too.
Mac Tonight.
I've been told Mac Tonight
is online,
a white supremacy symbol.
As if he doesn't suck enough.
I can't even show my kids
Pepe the Frog cartoons.
Memes and numerology.
[ Scoffs ] Master race, indeed.
Speaking of Mac,
I got some nice fan art.
It's very troubling to me.
That hurts my...
I guess we're toasting
Caucasians.
Someone -- somebody wrote,
excuse me.
This is a comment sent in.
"The running joke about this
being nominated for an Emmy
is thin at best."
But -- But it's not a joke.
It did get nominated, twice.
Lost both times,
which felt like four times,
because of the recounts
I demanded.
We always think
there's a chance,
even when they announce
somebody else.
I blame "La La Land"
or "Moonlight,"
whichever one you want to blame.
But the older the person
reading your category,
the more you think,
"Well, hold on.
Let's give it a beat."
The word is pronounced
"facultative."
Said it wrong last week.
"Facultative" means "occurring
optionally in response
to circumstances
rather than by nature."
For example, I'll use it
a sentence for you, Shoe.
"Leaving a snoozer
of a 'Corrections' comment
like that is facultative."
Oh, um...
There's difference
between harakiri and seppuku.
Harakiri is
the act of disembowelment.
Seppuku is the whole ritual.
And part of the ritual
is someone stands behind you,
and after the disembowelment,
they decapitate you
as an act of mercy.
And they say you can always tell
how your friends feel about you,
how quickly they volunteer
to do that part.
If you're like, "Well, bad news.
I got my seppuku scheduled."
They're like, "I can be there."
I don't know if I have
any friends who would --
Oh, Samberg.
"Uranus,"
we're told,
the incorrect way to say it.
Here's an interesting thing.
And I looked it up, and I guess
there's some truth to it,
that Dan Rather didn't want to
say "Uranus" on television,
so he started
calling it "Uran-us."
Peter Jennings called it
"Ur-anus,"
and Tom Brokaw called it --
[ Garbled ] Uranus.
I literally
just texted with him.
[ Ringtone playing ]
Oh. That's him.
Hey, I just did my Tom Brokaw.
Can you do your Brian Williams
for everybody?
-[ As Brian Williams ]
I'm Brian Williams.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really good.
Ah.
Got a lot of suggestions
on how to stop chewing my nails.
I appreciate it and want
to give each a fair hearing
and a meaningful response.
"Try calcium magnesium
supplements."
No.
"When my daughter was young,
she used to chew on hers,
so now we use Vicks VapoRub."
No.
"I kicked the nail-biting habit
easily
by getting braces on my teeth."
No.
"Seth, you got to cut
your nails and then paint them."
No.
"I took bupropion
to quit smoking,
and I quit biting my fingernails
after 50 years."
No.
Here's how I'm going
to stop chewing my nail.
Willpower.
And
so far, it's going pretty good.
Let's take a look.
[ Mumbling to self ]
I guess that's about it.
See me next week.